the russo brothers have officially
revealed to us
how exactly captain america was able to
lift mjolnir in avengers in game and
it's quite a twist it's not what you
think
how's it going everybody it's warren and
we're gonna talk about quite possibly
the best scene of avengers in game
captain america lifting and using
mjolnir
i'll break it down in this video but
first be sure to subscribe i'm picking
three winners at the 400
000 subscriber mark to choose one item
from the marvel legend series collection
i'll get into more details at the end of
the video
so many people think that captain
america became
worthy to lift mjolnir in avengers end
game in that moment where thor needed
him
but that's not true and also many people
believe that he became worthy after the
events of civil war because he finally
told tony that he knew bucky murdered
his parents
many people believe that he couldn't
lift mjolnir in age of ultron because he
still kept this secret from tony
however this is not true as well
actually according to the russo brothers
captain america has
always been worthy enough to lift
mjolnir and we finally got to see him do
it in avengers end game we even got to
see him summon lightning
now for those of you who do not know you
have to be worthy to pick up mjolnir
it's an enchantment that odin thor's
father placed on it in thor number one
but whoever is found worthy possesses
the power of thor which is why captain
america was able to summon lightning
translation yes well that's uh
that's a very very interesting theory i
have a simpler one
you're all not worthy
so if captain america was always able to
lift mjolnir how come he couldn't in
avengers age of ultron
well according to the russo brothers he
could he just chose not to in an
interview with a happy sad confused
podcast the russo brothers said
in our heads he was always able to wield
it he didn't know that until the moment
in ultron when he tried to pick it up
but capped sense of character and
humility and out of difference to thor's
ego
cap in that moment realizing he can move
the hammer decides not to
this is probably one of the most captain
america things i've ever heard
all of the avengers are sitting there
trying to lift mjolnir and thor's
telling everybody that they're not
worthy
everybody is trying super hard to lift
up this hammer
are you even pulling are you on my team
just represent pull
all right let's go and then it's captain
america's turn to go and grab mjolnir
and he realizes that he actually can
lift it up but he decides not to
to not hurt thor's feelings we did see
thor's face when captain america
nudged it just a little bit and captain
america nudged it because he realized
that he actually could lift it
but seeing thor's concerned and freaked
out face he decides
not to because he's captain america and
evidently in that moment thor seemed to
know that captain could lift it
because in avengers end game when thor
finally sees him wield it he says i knew
it
so there you have it captain america was
always able to lift mjolnir because he
was always worthy because he's captain
america
and this comes directly from the russo
brothers themselves the directors of
captain america the winter soldier
captain america civil war and
avengers infinity war and avengers
endgame this doesn't come as a surprise
to me at all it sounds
exactly like something captain america
would do but let me know what you think
about this
and now for the giveaway stuff as i
mentioned when i hit 400 000 subscribers
i will be picking not one but three
winners
each winner will get to choose one item
from the marvel legends series
collection that they want
you'll have multiple chances to enter
and there will be multiple ways that you
can enter that i'll reveal an upcoming
video but of course you must be
subscribed to my channel if you want to
enter
don't forget to drop a like if you
enjoyed the video and be sure to let me
know your thoughts on this video
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
avengers assemble
you